hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be looking at a very very solid defense
in the queen's indian defense and it
starts out with pawn to d4 Knight to f6
simple development moom trying to
control the center pawn to c4 and pawn
to e6 from black now a lot of times here
you will see players bring their Knight
to c3 very good place for this Knight
and simple development move but this
comes into the nimzo-indian defense and
a lot of white players don't like to
play this because a lot of times they'll
have doubled pawns and even top players
a lot of GM's will try to avoid the
nimzo-indian defense and so instead of
playing Knight to c3 they instead play
Knight to f3 and what this does is you
can see a few things
white would really like to control the
e4 square he'd realize he can't pushes
his pawn forward right away because our
knight on f6 sits here and it defends
this square and so he would really like
to play his Knight to c3 right away and
defend this pawn that he could push
forward to e4 but as we talked about
before a lot of players don't like to
play the nimzo-indian defense so this
brings us to the queen zenith indian
defense and this allows black in this
case to bring his pawn to b6 getting
ready to fianchetto his bishop to this
b7 square and try to gain access and
gain control of these light squares as
you can see here black already controls
this e4 and d5 square with his knight
here and so this is another hyper modern
defense where blacks really looking to
have a very solid defense and at the
same time control the center with his
minor pieces now why it does have a few
options here and so we're gonna take a
look at some of the most popular ones
that you will see but more times than
not that the move that you're going to
see from white to combat our b6 move is
white playing pawn to g3 and he does
this because it's very very important
for him not to just give up these light
squares
it's very important for a white to at
least try and hold them off by means of
Bishop to g2 eventually doesn't have to
do that right away but you really don't
want to just concede this entire
LightSquared diagonal to black because
that really gives black the opportunity
to counter-attack anytime he wants to
so this is a very properly move that you
will see from white and now here black
actually has two main options one I
prefer but but two that you'll see a lot
and the first one is the old line and I
don't prefer it too much but you will
see a lot of play with it and that's
Bishop to b7 this is really more of a
passive game I know it he is on this
long diagonal and he's trying to control
this but it is passive compared to his
second move that we'll talk about here
in just a minute but from here the
LightSquared Bishop for white can come
to g2 again contesting these light
squares that we have here Black's really
trying to hold on to this square on e4
he really doesn't want white to be able
to push his pawn to e4 and just have a
complete dominant center control here
from here black can simply bring his
Bishop to e7 again Black's playing very
passive but keep in mind there is a lot
of variations in the Queen's in the
defense that we'll talk about the black
actually has a lot of options to not
play as passive then he can play a
little bit more aggressively but in this
variation if he does want to just
solidify this light squares then he can
bring his bishop to b7 and then bring
his Bishop to e7 and then both sides are
going to castle on the King side and
from here White's just going to continue
his development here with Knight to c3
as you can see here now our Bishop
coming to b4 is it with an Enzo in the
in defense it's really not going to hold
down it's not going to lock down this
this Knight pin to the King because the
King
is castled on the kingside shows you can
see right here a fairly normal game that
you'll see in the Queen's Indian defense
and the old line where the bishop came
to b7 the White King is very very well
protected in this look nice little Kings
Indian defense if you will if you're
familiar the queens and kings in the in
defense it's kind of have that defense
going on at the same time we have our
LightSquared Bishop is very good but our
King is safe but really White has a lot
of sinner control here so this this is
an option so so keep this in mind but
the second option is actually Bishop to
a6 and that's kind of want to want to
talk about a little bit more because
that's what I recommend and I've had a
little bit more success with that one
myself so we'll go ahead and get into
that next variation that I do want to
look at is Bishop to a6 now again the
traditional play is Bishop to b7 but
actually think that Bishop excuse me
Bishop to a6 it's a much better move it
definitely is more aggressive so if
you're if you're a more aggressive
player like myself I think that Bishop
to a6 is going to be a much powerful
move so you can see here we're attacking
this pawn on c4 and white really doesn't
have a lot of good options to defend it
he doesn't want to bring his knight to
d2 it's not a very good place for his
knight he really wants to bring his
Knight to c3 eventually at the same time
he's blocking off his Queen which he
does not want to do if he brings his
Queen to c2 which you'll see a lot of
people want to do then he's really not
paying a lot of attention to this pawn
on d4 which right now since white really
is paying attention to these dark
squares he's trying to control the dark
squares and not the light squares with
this pawn on d4 his queen is no longer
defending it so from here white can
really try to take advantage of this
pawn on d4 now a lot of people say Kevin
why can't we just bring our pawn to e3
simple discovery defense on the c4 pawn
but you can see here what's defending
this pawn on c4 it's this bishop on f1
and since white played pawn to d3 he
really wants to fianchetto his bishop to
g2 there's no sense of playing g3 if
he's going
have this bishop on f1 defending this
pawn because as soon as you see and
kiddos then he's gonna have to have
another defender come to defend this c4
pawn so instead the most common move
that you will see is pawn to b3 and from
here black and play Bishop to b4 now
this is very important because before as
we talked about or Knight to c3 is no
longer possible from white but a lot of
people if they get the moves mixed up
instead of Bishop to a6 if they bring
their Bishop to b4 first now Knight to
c3 is possible now a lot of white
players again like to avoid this because
they don't like double pawns but you can
see here this is a little bit different
variation because the pond here is on b2
so it's very important that we one bring
out our Bishop d6 to attack this pawn
but also to get this pawn to b3 so it's
out of the way and we're bringing our
bishop now to b4 then the knight can no
longer come to c3 because then we'll
just capture it and go up three points
and just GG white there so from here
White has two options and the worst
option for him is Knight to d2 and this
is actually going to be a trap that I'm
gonna make a video on just here in a
minute but the second move and the best
option is to bring his Bishop to d2 and
so if you are playing as white this is
your best option if you do see
however Knight coming to d2 make sure
you check out the trap video and see
what to do there but for time restraints
I'm gonna go ahead and just get into a
few other options here but just keep in
mind that if what you really want to do
is just attack attack attack in my
opinion so I think that a six really
gives you that opportunity now you can
also bring your pawn to b5 if you really
want to keep in mind black soft options
here if you look at it you really don't
want to fianchetto both sides we can
castle on the King side if we want to
now obviously if he plays this Knight to
d2
then we're going to lay our track but if
he brings his Bishop to d2 and we want
to retreat and bring our Bishop back to
e7
we can still castle in the Kings side we
have a lot of counter play that we can
have we can bring your pawn to c5 we can
bring our pawn to d5 if we really wanted
to we could bring our pawn to b5 but as
you can see this is a little bit more
aggressive play from black so black does
have some options if he does come to a6
and I've had a lot more success playing
as black with a6 than b7 that's partly
just because I'm more aggressive than
passive but you can play around with
both of them and see what fits you best
so we're going to take a look at a few
more variations more importantly if
white does not bring his pawn to g3
right away in the beginning the next
variation is the Petrosian variation
it's pawn to a3 as you can see White's
avoiding this pawn to g3 Fink heading on
the kingside and instead he really wants
to bring his Knight to c3 but he doesn't
want to have to worry about this Bishop
on b4 pinning down his Knights at the
king so instead he's gonna play pawn to
a3 now a lot of people will say go ahead
black and go in fee and carry your
Bishop and you know just play normally
but I'm a very aggressive player and I
like to play aggressive lines so in this
case I've actually had a lot of success
with pawn to c5 now a lot of times from
here white we'll just come down with
this pawn to d5 and now we can bring our
Bishop to a6 attacking this weak point
in with this pawn on c4 now if white
tries to capture and just comes down
then we're gonna take with our F pawn
and take on e6 and as you can see here
this is a little bit different
eventually we can push our pawn forward
with pawn to d5 and we have an extra
defender here that we can recapture with
and this is gonna be a very aggressive
variation in the Queen's Indian defense
for black once we get our Bishop
involved and we castle on the King side
this semi-open F file is going to be
very good for a rook
and as you can see your white has a very
solid game but this is gonna be a very
aggressive line for black so if you'd
like to mix things up if you don't want
to just play for a draw and you are
playing the Quin Queens in the in the
fence then I do definitely recommend
this and the last variation that we'll
talk about real quick is just Knight to
c3 and from here blacks gonna play
Bishop to b4 and this is the
nimzo-indian offense that you'll see so
I'll make another video on the
nimzo-indian defense but that's kind of
what this is based off of so hope you
guys enjoyed the video make sure you
check out the website and I'll see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching